you know and we're talking we're talking
about haters we're talking about people
that you know like oh like how does Tim
have this stuff you know and like if
only if only they could look behind the
curtain and see the consistency see the
hard work see the sweat see the jacked
the jacked up hands you know like the
hours that I put in 16 17 18 hours a day
you're like you want to know why my
businesses are successful it's because I
put everything into it and there's not a
recipe I do not own this like that hard
work with consistency over time equal
success and you know if you look at one
of these mats that have multiple world
champions on them right now let's turn
this thing around you see all these guys
killing it yeah getting ready
um these are the best in the world how
how and why are they the best like they
train with the best in the world they
surround themselves with the best they
seek the the best and um you know they
put their egos aside and go out there
and try to improve consistency with hard
work over time is going to give you
success much easier said than done
seek the best and put the effort in like
I get those things but how do you get
there because this is for the people
that that that are not in that position
these are the people that do not seek
the best their egos are threatened they
want to still be on top they might bring
people down like what are what's the
that they have to face so that they
can
they can actually transition into being
a valuable human I mean it's it's
heartbreaking when I see somebody that
wants to to be something and I know
they'll never do what it takes to be
that right and
um
and there has to be intrinsic intrinsic
is is something that is self-motivating
inside of you right so as you're getting
ready for a fight high on the emotion
I'm getting ready to go overseas on a
deployment you know I I have a ton of
adrenaline you know I have a little bit
of fear I know that I'm going to be
going into a in a non-permissive
environment where you know people could
even want to kill me like I have all of
this um natural motivator well I'm not
going to get better in that little bit
of time leading up to that deployment
where my emotion the solution of me
wanting to get better is is motivating
me the time that I'm actually going to
get better is the time before that when
I have to be showing up I have to be
technically working on a skill I have to
be trying to find how to get to that
next level I'm putting that ego aside
um
um I'm seeking out professionals again I
think I'm a pretty talented shooter I
think I'm a pretty talented Grappler I
think I was a pretty talented Fighter
um I would go all over the world to find
these people to train with me
um they would beat me I didn't like that
you know um that doesn't feel good
because you like to win
that is a win you're not going to get
better in an environment that you're the
best you know you have to find areas
where other people are challenging you
and pushing you and only in that
struggle will growth occur
so consistency so not just doing it when
you need to but literally making a
lifestyle out of challenging yourself
and putting yourself up against the best
over and over again all the time you
know I say that's intrinsic that that is
discipline
um that emotion leading up to going
overseas that emotion that you have
before a fight that emotion that you
have after you go to a seminar that
emotion that you have after you go to a
driving course that ends that ends I
don't know what three days five days
maybe a week what do you do for the next
three months
that's discipline and that's where
consistency is and if you don't have
that and you don't have what it's going
to take for you whatever that goal is
you know whether it's going to be being
a better father you know it's being um a
professional athlete it's been the best
driver like you're not gonna ever be
that without that discipline that
consistency with hard work over time how
much of that I mean
like I I just have this theory that
human nature is to do the minimum and
like my minimum was just different like
I got yelled at for being only a half a
second quicker than everybody on the
racetrack like my minimum was not very
low it was pretty high but I have this
theory that people just that's to do the
minimum so like how much can you
actually learn later you know I got
disciplined when I was a kid but if I
was a lazy person that didn't have
discipline didn't have goals didn't have
Vision didn't have bravery
um like that's so hard to learn later so
you know I think before we kind of talk
about
younger because that's that's where
we're going to get to next like when
you're older it's difficult you know I
like in my own world I do a lot of
spiritual growth and also like um
personality and emotional growth and all
that stuff and like I tell everyone it
sucks like if you really want to grow
and evolve it's gonna suck you it's not
just like oh I'm just punching me in the
arm a few times no it's like meltdown
like you have to really go through it so
what is the suck as an adult to actually
get to the point where you have
discipline and you can be consistent
like what's what is what what are what
are some things you have to face your
childhood your parents what your new
friends move cities yeah you you are 100
right that the earlier you start the
easier it is but at no point is it ever
too late
um and and that is a lie where it's you
know you can't teach old dog new tricks
that's a lie go get a dog I can show you
I have Belgian malawas that um yeah it's
easier to teach them young but yeah
they're the best you know and and you
can teach them anything anytime
um so what are the things that we have
to put on this on the side
um it you are who you surround yourself
with and you know you the bar set for
you was a high bar the bar of
expectation of being a half a second
faster on the track you know everyone in
my family were high Achievers the bar
even a two-time you know fighting for
the world title two different times when
I came back home my dad was like
but do they call you a champion you know
like you have a long road to be a
contender again because you lost that
fight just cool you're there but you
didn't win it you know like um you know
we have Olympians we have we have people
in the Hall of Fame and in my family and
and that's that's the bar
and um so at what point do you start
sitting the bar for yourself for you and
your family for you and your children
for you and your and your spouse where
you guys are going to say like we
collectively are going to start eating
better
and I know this for a fact that if
you're faithful in the small things
you're going to be faithful in the big
things there's no way that you are going
to see big results without making small
changes and those small changes matter
when General Mattis was asked what is
the most important thing that he does in
a day he said he makes his bed that's
the first small choice that he can make
in a day is to make his bed and then the
next thing is does he have a cup of
coffee or does he have a big glass of
water it's better for him to have a big
glass of water so he does you know does
he have a sugary cereal for breakfast no
he just has a nice couple eggs scrambled
with uh some sourdough toast now he's
three decisions into his day and he's
made three great decisions now we're
starting to see a trend that's going to
happen and carry us through the day but
more importantly you're going to see
momentum of energy that starts
compounding you know the exponential J
curve or whatever you start making
better decisions lots of little
decisions it gets easier to make the
harder big decisions but you will not
make the harder big decision without
being faithful in the smaller decisions
so again it's discipline love that love
that so much all right
um okay let's talk about the school
because I like when I saw you post about
doing the school I was like I don't even
have kids and I just have dogs I have
Belgian Malinois a little uh miniature
Siberian Husky but um but but I don't
have kids I just my sister has four and
obviously all my friends have kids
and where I come from with school is
that I have a GED I left school when I
was 16 I moved to England I went racing
and like I don't have formal education
but I wouldn't call myself stupid I
would say that
um that I'm pretty smart and I feel like
in school there's just so many things
that even at the point that I left I
don't use so like I just that's where I
come from from school and so I look at
look at so many aspects of it and I just
think man these so many things feel like
they need to change so like what are the
things that are wrong with school
because obviously it's gonna it led you
to to the place of of making creating
one so what did you see that you were
not okay with yeah so so education for
let's let's separate education from
school and right now those are being
conflated between the two those are very
different things like just because you
didn't go to proper formal education or
proper formal school does not mean that
you're not educated right if you if you
look at the the original Socratic deep
thinkers the philosophers they were not
ones that's that went to a proper school
right they read books they discussed it
they debated and in that their their
learning was elevated
um their education was elevated that is
different than school and we've done a
very dangerous thing where by conflating
school with education we think that you
have to go to school to become educated
yeah if you look at the smartest people
on the planet right now they did not go
to school but they are highly educated
and uh and and I first wanted to find
those terms because you know for us in
the United States for us to say okay
he's well educated okay you know he's a
graduate degree you know he um we're
we're on his undergrad he went to this
school ivy league to this school now
we're saying okay he's Highly Educated
that's not true that is that is a very
dangerous thing so for us I want
critical thinkers for my school apogee
we have two programs apogee strong which
is an online mentorship where we're
really focusing on how people think how
fathers treat their children how um how
you're going to be ahead of a household
as as a mom or dad and how young men and
young women approach life that's apogee
strong and then there's the actual
physical campus called apogee what does
apogee mean apogees to Summit it's to um
to reach the Pinnacle of a moment you
know if you if you are climbing at
Everest when you stick that flag in the
top that is the moment of apogee where
you have you have successfully met your
goal of reaching the the crescendo of a
moment a crescendo of a mat of a
masterpiece could could be called an
apogee okay
if you like this clip and you want to
hear the whole episode click at the
bottom of your screen